imagine spending three decades in prison
for a crime a judge has said you didn't
commit
well that's Krishna Maharaja's life at
81 years old and still a British citizen
we spoke to him before coronavirus
closed down the world and delayed
further a hearing which could finally
set him free it was in Miami in 1987
that he was convicted for the murder of
two business associates in a hotel his
lawyers list a catalogue of failings in
the system and a reported confession by
a drug cartel hit man last year a judge
said maharajah had proved his innocence
but the verdict has yet to be overturned
half of his sentence was spent on death
row when the phone Magoo gee I passed
out I fainted I just couldn't believe
you could be found guilty for something
you didn't do murder what does that feel
like what is that
can you explain what that's like you
know it is like dying if you know what I
mean right then another debt you end up
on death row for 17 years or something
you did not do when you know you you're
innocent how difficult is it to sit in a
prison cell it's very very difficult
it's very very very difficult we wake up
every morning
oh god what a god what am I doing here
these people knew I were in with them
what's your emotion about what's
happened to you are you angry about it
very first freaking after 33 years
knowing that I'm innocent if that bit I
went from living like a prince to living
like an animal home now is this prison
on the edge of Miami half an hour's
drive away from his wife Marita's home
she visits every week although there
have been times when she doubted she
could go on one day I was driving down
to to see Chris and of course every time
I you know then my the pain was all the
time there
I say just you see that tree goes drive
straight to that tree and something came
up and see what about Greece I was about
to there is a split of the second I
would think up my head of life in
fighting him but what about Greece
I don't hate anybody I should prefer
them every day but I think it's gonna be
not what they do
I think Chris did not have to make that
face they destroy our life we've been
through hell we need some nice quiet
time now we are old we don't need a lot
of things I don't want the life that I
had before my dream is to be with Greece
and after that maybe have a nice dog you
know just people are you confident that
day will come
are you confident Chris will be released
well sure I'm not good for the Bible
true and I don't know when it's the case
of the hundreds that I've done that I'm
most convinced the guys innocent and
here he is age 81 still in prison for
Chris Morales lawyer it is frustrating
when the judge has ruled that chris is
innocent by clear and convincing
evidence and that no reasonable juror
could convict him that's not enough to
set him free
this is what drives me rather mad about
the case and you know obviously it's
much harder for chris and maureesa to
deal with and he sees a more urgent
threat those prisons are a petri dish of
the virus where the virus is breeding
and you know there's Chris he had one
death sentence for a crime he didn't do
back in 1987 he got another really when
we got him a life sentence because he's
not eligible for parole
Tilly's 101 and what I'm really afraid
of is this is the third death sentence
that they're going to manage to execute
him by kovat 19 back in that prison
though Chris Maharaj remains hopeful
lots of people in prison say I'm
innocent
and to the people in the UK where you're
from and who say why should we believe
your source where everybody in the UK
who knows me who must know I'm innocent
soon they'll have their hearing they've
got to vindicate me they've got the
degree me innocent everything is on the
record I think of that every day I want
to be on the first plane to England
I mean England is my home no got to
clear my name of course and you're
confident you'll do that oh yes I'm 100
centered in God on death row every
morning I got up I said Psalm 23 the
Lord is my shepherd I shall not want
and I shall dwell in the house of the
Lord forever forever amen Greg Milam Sky
News Miami